even dozens of hours in the Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild remains packed
with mechanics and concepts that were
still finding out about with so many
veiled secrets still hidden in its
mysterious world we've compiled nine
more useful things to know to help you
on your journey
be wary there are potential spoilers
ahead if you love this video like it and
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more features on breath of the wild and
be sure to watch our previous video on
the nine things I wish I knew before
starting
[Music]
early on if you need to swim across a
body of water but don't have the
necessary stamina and speed to clear the
distance you can take off your clothes
to swim faster though make sure to put
your armor back on when there are
enemies in the water as your defense is
incredibly low while naked utilize this
technique until you acquire the Zora
armor which greatly enhances your
swimming speed while providing you
defensive power
when you're traveling in between towns
you'll encounter travelling merchants
who can sell you various equipment or
cooking ingredients be sure to browse
their wares when possible for supplies
you might need however when it rains
merchants bust out their rare items for
example a merchant that typically sells
the raw meat ingredient during sunny
weather will list the better more
effective raw prime meat ingredient when
it rains if storm clouds start to appear
seek out merchants in the area you never
know what rare items you might be able
to purchase lighting grass on fire
creates a temporary updraft that you can
use to skyrocket yourself up into the
air with your glider this has a variety
of applications such as creating height
between you and an approaching guardian
or propelling yourself upward to give
you more time in the air
[Music]
it's actually possible to ride wild
animals such as bears and deer like you
would a horse so long as you approach it
carefully and with stealth bonuses
activated unfortunately wild animals
aren't the most useful or reliable
mounts as they're far less compliant
than horses
you also can't register them at stables
for future travels despite these
limitations riding wild animals is a fun
novelty what we're taking advantage of
when the opportunity presents itself
after all who doesn't want to ride a
bear
[Music]
while climbing if you jump when your
stamina wheel is in the red you'll
propel yourself upward twice the usual
distance this is a handy last resort
technique that can be a lifesaver when
you're just about to reach the top of a
mountain but can't make it by climbing
alone
[Music]
if you miss an enemy with an arrow don't
worry it's possible to pick it back up
the same works for enemy arrows which
you can pick up when they land at your
feet you can even retrieve the arrows
that gets stuck to your shield by
putting it away this is a great way to
farm hundreds of arrows by the way
regardless when a battle is over
make sure to mine the battlefield for
all the arrows that missed their mark
similar to The Legend of Zelda Wind
Waker HD you can take selfies in the
breath of the wild with your sheikah
slates camera simply turn on the camera
with the L button and then press X to
activate self portrait mode moving the
left stick in different directions
changes links pose while in this mode
maximizing the photos social media
effectiveness
it's made apparent early on that you can
scan amiibo to get new weapons and items
but if you scanned amiibo of classic
Zelda characters you can get special
armor and weapons from past games for
example when you scan the toon link
amiibo you have the chance of acquiring
winwaker inspired armor pieces you can
even obtain new mounts like the iconic
Epona
which you can get when you scan the
Super Smash Brothers series link amiibo
it's worth noting that each amiibo can
only be scanned once per day and that
items are randomized in addition certain
items are only available to its
respective amiibo so don't expect to get
sheikhs mask from the Ganondorf amiibo
if you're interested in dawning on the
classic link outfits from past games be
sure to take advantage of breadth of the
wilds of meebo functionality do whatever
it takes to make it happen
whether that be scanning in your fans
expansive collection of Zelda amiibo or
forking over your life savings to buy
your own
[Music]
have you ever recklessly let your trusty
steed die in the middle of a battle and
spent the rest of your journey in a
debilitating state of regret and
self-loathing opponent jr. I'm sorry I'm
so sorry
fret not it's actually possible to bring
your horse back to life but you can't do
it with the help of the folks at the
stable rather you need to seek out the
help of melania the great horse fairy to
find ur head to the licked our region to
the south and find the Highland stable
from there head south east towards the
horse god bridge when you reach the end
of the path you'll find what looks like
a great fairy fountain examine it in pay
Melania the flat fee of a thousand
rupees to access her services talk to
her again and she'll work her magic to
bring your steed back from the grave
note that you can do this as many times
as you'd like at no additional rupy cost
to you so you never have to go back to
that dark place of grief ever again
what secrets have you found let us know
in the comments below and for more
coverage on The Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild including our full review be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]